yeah okay so it is pretty gross not only
do you have the X's and Y's together on
the left-hand side you've got them
together on the right-hand side in
nestled inside a function so we should
expect that the river this to be really
gross but that also makes it a perfect
headed for a positive education because
the X's and Y's a tangled up so implicit
means I don't have to untangle okay so
how does it work
you just take both sides you
differentiate with respect to whatever
variable you want I could differentiate
with respect to Y if you like there's a
whole topic in unique actually called
partial differential equations PDE s
for sure and it burnt my brain viens
because the whole idea is that instead
of saying you know I've got a function
and a differentiator right it's a
function of X instead you got functions
and it's like you've got all these
different variables here let's check out
of it like a Sigma or something okay to
our billion different variables that go
into it
inputs which actually make sense in real
life outputs tend to happen for all
kinds of everyone like say whether okay
there's like air pressure and humidity
and temperature and blah blah blah
anyway and then they say well you can't
differentiate it with respect to all the
variables you're gonna do what so it
should pick one and then instead of
using a - notation they put it down here
so that means differentiate with a fidex
or differentiate with respect to theta
and this this completely so much get
this university semesters like 13 weeks
right I got four weeks into the semester
before I understood that when they write
a theater there they mean differentiate
with respect to theta so you can imagine
how little I comprehended for this
person
we're sort of doing the same thing here
so I'm gonna friendship with 15 X so
that's Y DX okay now on the left hand
side I have a product right it's just
that so this is just a wolf or an XE
okay it is right so our you take the
second function y its unchanged you do
the second function now instead of
writing X - because that looks just like
you said part one I'm gonna write the
food-themed yawns so you're
differentiate the first function which
is D on DX of s a B you do the same
thing reverse order
okay so first function unchanged and
second function differentiated with
respect to X okay I'll leave that
left-hand side I'll simplify the second
now you do the right-hand side we just
chain rule okay so this is sec when
you're differentiate SEC you get second
10 okay now sorry I skipped a step
because of the chain rule I should
probably differentiate the inside first
and then the outside okay so the
derivative of the inside is X plus y
okay so I'm gonna differentiate X plus y
that would be my inside derivative
whatever that is and then I multiply
that by the derivative of the outside
which is SEC 10 and 10 okay now probably
should be careful because this looks
like I'm differentiating a whole lot but
I'm not okay
there's the driven inside and this is a
total separate thing inside outside
happy alright now I can start to
evaluate some mighty reviews over here
I've got Y times the derivative of X
which is just 1
here I've got x times and do I the
exactly what I'm after
so X
okay now by the way I try as much as
possible to write the derivative second
so that you don't confuse this with this
and I got my differentiating x and y
which is what I did here
and it's not what you want to do you've
already done that so that's why I
started the X on the front here again
derivative of X is just 1 and then the
derivative of Y is 2 idea okay and then
you have this long disgusting thing over
here
okay now from here I've done all the
differentiating all I have to do is make
the one DX the subject that's it
okay so in order to do that number one
I've got to get this Y over here so I'm
just gonna say - why
okay and then I've got to get this this
dy/dx like that I've got to get on the
other side okay so that's what I'll do
on this step I've got X lots of July on
DX and then how many Lots do I have here
I have take a breath step x + y 10 x + y
what's off dy on the X it's gross but it
is yes I it's - yeah okay
over on this side I've got one one of
this left over that's from this one and
then I've got minus y so now Poland
dy/dx for his own I factorize it out so
let me do that here maybe chick doing
there today you only get to factorize
okay so now what I want it on its own dy
on the X just divide through okay which
actually this this will be kind of
symmetry to it right cuz you're going X
- sec x + y 10 x + y right and that's
very very similar to what I have here so
I'm just gonna sign a minus sign all on
the front just so I can write the
denominator in the same order which is
why - is awesome
Finnick
tada like I said it looks weird cuz um
there's all the external wires but
that's what you have to expect that's
what it just does probably the hardest
step was this one just making sure
you're careful with the product and with
your chain